にはちゃんとテキストいっぱいありますし
勉強できるし 真剣に勉強するとその人々が自分の心の中に現れてくるんです
私は知識すごく好きな性格のとんでもない性格かもしれませんだけど
で 生まれちゃったんだから
性格はしょうがないんだから
自分でワサワサ作ったものじゃないんだから
で 阿羅漢第八 八十人の阿羅漢の中で
やっぱりいつでも気に入るのは気に入ってるのはサーリプッタ尊者ですか
知恵の第一と言われている
ですから 自分にとってはサーリプッタ尊者の思考方向やら考え方やら生活やら
もう全部この手に取っているように心で感じるんです
涙が来るんです 感じると
こんなにも立派な人がいるんですかと
そうすると 自分の人生はすごく根底をされちゃうし
だから私も何の苦しみもなく仏教を語れるんです
それはもうサーリプッタ尊者のおかげなんです
何のことなく 人はどんな質問したっていい
仏教に対するどんな疑問生まれたって
この場合はこう答える方がいいやと
瞬時に頭に浮かんじゃうんです
そこはもうすぐ出てくるのはサーリプッタ尊者の知恵なんです
なんとなく一体になっているように感じになるんです
で 何回もこのもう巻き添えになっちゃって
他の人に仏教の人ではなくて
この で じゃあ困っちゃったと
どうしようかと思った瞬間で
じゃあサーリプッタ尊者だったらどうするかなと思ったら
じゃあこう答えればいいやと答えた瞬間で
その人はそれっきりで仏教の話をやめたんです
違う宗教の人でしたけど
ですから そういう風に念想の場合は
まあ自分の性格に合うような阿羅漢
誰かを選んで その阿羅漢はどのような修行をしたんですか？どのようなステップをしたんですか？どのような性格でありましたか？とよく感じてみる
で それによって自分の性格もどんどん成長するんです
で 私はモクレン尊者の瞑想はしたことがないんだから
全く神通力は全然ないんです
もう先を見えるところか
今の時も何が起こるか
時間さえ忘れちゃうんです
でも どんな神通力を持ってる人にでも
仏教の概念とか知識としてはもう負けないと自信はあるんです
で あのアーナンダ尊者またいて
で ウパーリ アーナンダとか八十人いますけどね
そういう風なこの一応記録あるお坊さんたちのことを念じてみること
あるいはまた他のお坊さんたち
ある瞬間で悟ったお坊さんいますよと
例えばこのマハーシ大長老もよく使っている例がありまして
この法句経で第一番目の偈文見てくるし
またアーナンダ尊者の悟ったことですか
アーナンダ尊者は徹夜してずっと悟っていて
もうなかなか悟れないんですね
それで自分がやりすぎだと
ちょっと休んだ方がいいやと思ってベッドに寝ようとした
その瞬間で足をベッドから地面から上げて
頭はベッドに行ってない
いわゆる寝てない 座ってもない
その瞬間で悟り開いたんだとというケースとか
それはいつでもサティを使いなさいということで言ってますけど
で あるお坊さんがもう死にかけて死ぬ瞬間に悟ったとか
いろんな話があるんですね
そういう風にその話を聞くと
自分たちにも役に立つ
あ 私もこの場合はこうすればいいとか
重病になって死にかけていて
一般の人だったらもう死にたくない死にたくないと泣きっぱなしで
で かなり強烈な病気になったところでお坊さんたちは泣くんじゃなくて
もう逆なことを考えちゃうんですね
神通力で誰か私の病気治してちょうだいとか
宗教はそのためにあるんだとか
そんな話じゃないんです
こんな汚い醜い病弱の体に生まれてもう嫌だと
死ぬのはもう一番ありがたいんだと
でも煩悩あって死ぬのはもうけしからんだと
それだけ怖いんだと 病気は怖くないんだと
どうせ死ぬんだから今死んだってもいいんだと
でも穢れた心では死ぬのは嫌です
それは恥ずかしいんだと言って
自分の態度を考えて もう死ぬ瞬間前でも悟り開いて死ぬと
亡くなると そういういろいろストーリーいっぱいありますから
そういうところから我々はもうそういうのは観察する
そういうのは瞑想なんです
で そのように仏教だけの
瞑想もありまして 他の宗教から借りた瞑想もあります
その中に神を念じる瞑想も一つあるんです
それはデーヴァタの八節というんです
なぜならば 他宗教では
念心と言うんですかね
神様を念じる瞑想は当然ありますから
ヒンドゥー教でもバクティヨーガっていうのは念心ですね
神様を念じるヨーガなんです
ハーレーラーマハーレークリシュナとか歌ったりとかね
このハーレークリシュナムーブメントはこれこれやってるんですね
そこで頭おかしくなる人はいますから
その頭おかしくなることは自分たちの神秘体験だと
何時間でも歌うんですよ
あの太鼓 タブラやらあれいろいろ楽器を使って
でも歌はただハーレーラーマハーレークリシュナハーレークリシュナハーレーラーマハーレークリシュナ
それだけ それでやっぱり瞬間生まれるんですよ
自我ない瞬間 あればっかりやってるんだから
それでもその上踊る 新宿とかあちこちでお目にかかったことあるでしょうと思いますけど
あるグループがね 白い服を着て
頭を剃って 楽器を持って踊ったりして
まあ音楽は別に気持ち音楽自体僕も別に嫌いということはないんですけど
まあ同じメロディずっと繰り返せちゃいますけど
嫌にならないんですね
普通だったらすごく嫌になっちゃいますけどね
で それを歌っていると
あまりにそれに集中しちゃうと
瞬間なんか我を忘れちゃうんです
我を忘れちゃう瞬間でする得る認識自体は
彼らが神秘体験と神と一体になったことやと言うんです
ですから 我を忘れる瞬間というのは大体の人間にあること
そういう工夫してでもできるもので
ですから 神を念じることを仏教でも使っているんです
でも 仏教では仏教的にやっぱり瞑想は変えちゃうんです
偉大なる神様 絶対神とか何とか念じたったら
とんでもない嘘を念じて体験しちゃうでしょうに
いわゆる合理的に絶対神っていうのはあるわけじゃないんで
合理的に見たってありえないんです
ですから そんなありえない人間の希望だけだからね
神がいてほしいという希望があるんです
ですから 希望を瞑想したらダメなんです
ですから だからといってその方法と
仏教ではこういう風に神を念じるんですね
神 神を念じる あっちこっちいっぱい神々がいるんだと
この部屋の中にも こちらに憑いてる何か
そういう霊がいるんだと
どこに それ何のためにかというと
ですから ずっと自分が見られているんだと
神々には この人間には私たちの心を見えませんだけど
例えば私は頭の中 とんでもない悪いことを考えちゃって
皆様知らないし いい人だとすごい誤解しちゃうでしょ
でも私は一人でいろんな良くないことを汚いこと
くだらないことを考えちゃうと
神々がいると信じちゃうと
もう知ってるんですね
向こう側が こちらの考え方
そうするとそう念じて
神々がいるんだって念じて
本当にいるんだと実感みたいなものを作って
自分の身口意の行動をコントロールする
頭の中でも悪いことを考えないようにする
頭の中でもこの畜生とか何とか考えちゃったら
もうそれをもう誰かに知られてるんだ
自分の無意識な心の働きまで全部見られているんだというと
まあ悪い行動はできなくなっちゃうんですね
それでどうなるかというと
心にはかすかにでも不善たる思考が生まれなくなっちゃうんですね
それはヴィパッサナー瞑想で悟るためにはものすごく必要な条件なんです
ですから ヴィパッサナー瞑想を支えるために
それも揃う そのために仏教ではいろんな神々の話はどんどんあるんです
ですから この単なるこのもう仏教はなんで知識的に喋ってて
なんで神々の話が出るんですかとか
そんなものはと文句言いたくなる人々いますけど
まあかえってそこら辺にまたいるんだと
神々はあっちこっち 信じておいた方がどうかで悟りのために役に立つんです
ですから 人間に一人で心は完璧に清らかにしようと思っても難しいんです
怒らないようにしますよと思ったって
怒ってしまっちゃうでしょうに
欲張らないようにしたっても欲張ってしまっちゃうでしょうに
だからなんかちょっと工夫しなくちゃということ
ですから この弱い心をそこでもう守られるんです
ですから 仏教で選んでいるこの四十種類にいくつしか説明いたしませんでしたけど
あの 仏教の解脱の道を支えるために工夫している四十なんです
時間を忘れて超能力や神秘体験を得ようというならば
数え切れないほどあるんです
でもそれで誤解を生まれて大変危険になる可能性はもう八十パーセント以上あるんです
パーセントは僕の勝手なことで
別に気にする必要ないんだけど
ものすごくあるんです
ですから 安全な瞑想 この四十はもう徹底的に安全なんです
それでもちゃんと指導者がいてやった方がいいのです
で この中で一番目に出てくるのはこのパテリーカシナと言うんです
パテリーっていうのは地水火風の地なんですね
よってパテリーカシナ
アポーカシナ ワーヨーカシナ
テーヨーカシナと四つあります
それからニーラカシナ
ピッタカシナ ローヒタカシナ
オーダカシナと四つありますね
八個 で 無常観はたくさんありまして
で まあそれで四十ありますけどね
今日はその話の時代時ではないんだけどね
これはアビダンマの後々出てきます
で 一応どうやってこの心が生まれるかっていうことを説明するためにこれ説明します
このパテリーカシナっていう場合は
この地という幻想は瞑想できません
どうしても それは幻想だからね
見えるわけじゃないし
体験できない その代わりに色対象を作っちゃうんです
昔はこの大体自分の手を開げて
またこれぐらいの輪を作っちゃうんです
まあセンチで言いますけど
まあ十二センチ十四センチぐらいの輪ですけど
ミリでセンチではなくて
インチで言えば センチで言えば十五センチぐらいの横
ダイメーター？ダイメーターなんですか？ダイメーター
輪の横の径 え？直径 で
15センチぐらいの直径の輪を作って
それ何でもいいんです
それに土を塗っちゃうんですね
土を練って持ってきて
丁寧に塗ると 塗ったらこの土色の輪をあるんですね
で 日本だったらすごく簡単な日本の何部屋というんですか
この和室ありますね そちらの壁ありますね
あの壁の色なんです ですから
壁紙を買ってきて輪を作っちゃえば
一番立派な昔とできなかったほど立派なものができちゃうんです
昔は手で塗ったりするんだから
いろいろギザギザこともことが出て出ますから
今の壁紙やりますから
あれすごく丁寧に作ってますから
それでも欠陥はいっぱいありますよ
そういうものも作って
もう軽く見えるところに置いておく
置いといて まず体綺麗にする
体を綺麗にして シャワーでお風呂でも入って
綺麗な服を着て やっぱり気持ちよくやらないといけないんです
落ち着かなくちゃいけないんです
で 不安だったら やっぱりいくらかのお守りをしなくちゃいけないんです
とにかく 心のこの次元が変わっちゃうと
いろいろこの問題が起こる可能性あるんですね
いわゆるこの 今まで幽霊なんか見たことがない人に見える可能性もあるんです
で 心の次元が変わっちゃうと
同じ次元の心にいじめられる可能性もあります
今 我々は人間だって人間の次元は全然変えませんだから
誰にもいじめることできないんです
でも 心の次元変わっちゃうと
その次元の他の生命がいたならば
もしこいつは嫌だなと思っちゃったら
もういじめられるんですね
そうすると なんかあまり良くないし
どうすることもできなくなっちゃうし
ですから いくらか自分を守らなくちゃいけない
そういうことで 仏教でも日本の神社と同じく守りの守りあるんです
その仏教の守りあるのは
もう人々にこの商売繁盛させるためとか
そんな意味ではないんです
瞑想するときは身を守るためなんです
それ今 一般的にまあよくやってますけどね
で これは別に不思議なことではないんです
この部屋に阿弥陀仏の教室だから
人数は決まっていて みんなお互いに顔を見て
お互いに人との塊を作っているんですね
全く新しい人が入っちゃったら
なんとなく抵抗生まれるでしょ
心の拒否反応になる そういうことなんです
この次元に他の人も入ろうとしているんだからということ
距離してやろう それは避けられないんです
存在というのはそういうものなんです
そこでちょっとしたお守りをしなくちゃいけないんです
清めだから 仏教 仏教の人々の場合は参詣をして御開眼を受けてという風なありますけど
それしなくたって別に問題ないんだけど
自分が自分が精神的に強いと思ったならば
別に問題ないんだけどね
すごい徹底的に科学的な人だったら問題何もないんです
お守りなくても大丈夫ですけどね
人はもう科学的で 科学的な人はなかなか僕はもう会ったことないほど
人間ってのは非科学的なんですね
科学者さえ ですからしょうがないんだけど
そういうふうな何かをお守りもするんですね
で しなくてもいい とにかく気持ちいい気持ちになって
体も清めて ある落ち着いている場所で
部屋で誰にも邪魔されないところで座って
そういう準備をして で
髪の毛も切って 曽根も切ってとかね
いろいろあるんです 部屋をちゃんと掃除してとか
そういうもう準備を全部しておかなくちゃいけない
それから土色の対象をじーっと見ているんです
それだけ体を動かさないで
じっと見ていて 全部考え方をやめるんです
だからやめるためには
やっぱり何か言葉を頭の中で回転させないと
すぐ考えちゃうんですね
それでこの何か一つの言葉を回転させちゃう
頭の中 仏教は大体このオームとかね
関係ない言葉はもう絶対使わない
呪文とか使ってはいけない
対象と関係ないんだから
またどんな妄想でも 例えばオームとオームと唱えたってもいいんだけど
オームについてどんな妄想でもできるでしょ
南無妙法蓮華経でもいいんだけど
それについてどんな妄想でもできますから
そういうのは使わない
仏教のどんな瞑想に使っても
ですから 今土色を見てるんだから
パーリ語だったらパテリーと言うんだから
パテリー パテリー パテリーと言うんです
頭の中で 日本語だったら土色
土色って何て言うのか言いにくいんですからね
だからちょっとそこら辺
ちょっとどうすればいいか僕はわからない
やっぱり流れる言葉でないと念じることできませんだからね
パーリ語の言葉はパタパタというのは簡単に流れるんです
パタパタパタパタと言ってるんです
それはパタパタの色だから
土の色だから 別に嘘じゃないし
何も妄想することはできない
それについて だから土土と言ったっても
なかなか発音しにくい
難しいしね 何かいい言葉はないんですかね
ですから ヴィパッサナー的には
見てます 見てますでもね
見えてます 見えてます
でも そういう言葉でもいいんです
それで見ことを集中するんです
それからいろいろ変化が起こるんです
いろいろ変化が起こるんです
で どんどんこの輪をそれだけ見ているんだから
それで目にそれしか入らなくなっちゃうんです
それしか入らなくなったから
普通だったらいろんなもの目に入るでしょ
それしか入らないということは
頭一杯土色だけになっちゃうんです
輪は見えなくなっちゃう
輪のところじゃなくて
すべっても全体的に同じ色に見えちゃうんです
ある水中録画出てる 小さな 15 センチぐらいの輪なんですけど
それだけ見ると目にそれだけの情報しかいかないんですね
そうすると 頭の中で 視覚のところで
その 1 1色しか受けてないんですね
そこで心にとってはもう空とほど大きく
もうどれくらい大きく感じる？その人の認識能力によります
空ぐらい巨大に見えるという人は
かなり知識的にすごい能力がある人なんです
ですから 自分の能力も見えてきますけどね
どれぐらい自分に物事を把握する能力があるかって
それぐらいに大きく見えるんです
すごい科学的なもので
全然不思議なところ何一つもないんです
で そこもあるかもしれませんし
あるいはまず大体明確にこの色を見えてくるんですね
たとえ日本の壁紙を持って見たっても
それは人間にギリギリ状態で一番綺麗に完璧に作ったものかもしれません
それでもそちらにいろんな欠陥があるんです
色の変化とか このこのいろんなすぶすぶでできているんだから
そのすぶすぶの違うところとか
ものすごくきめ細かく明確に見えてくるんですね
その時もそれはこの障害じゃなくて
この欠点見える状態と呼んです
欠点見える状態 普段は全然見えない
顕微鏡で見ない限りは
顕微鏡で見えているような感じで
きめ細かく見えてくる
それでもパタウィパタウィと続けちゃう
どんどん大きく見えてくる
それで最後にこのパタウィだけ見たいんだから
血管消えちゃって 綺麗なパタウィというものだけ見えてきます
この綺麗な純粋たる色を見えてくると
すごく気持ちよくなってくるんです
血管消えちゃったんだもん
体でものすごく楽になって
気持ちよくなって楽しくなってくる
それからこの原始状態でそのものを見えてくるんですね
大体我々人間に見えるものは何ですかね
原始的には光でしょ そこでこのパタウィという光が見えてくるんです
普段は光見えません 目では光を受け取って解釈して幻覚を見せているんです
光そのものは見えない
そこで瞑想した対象の中から
ちょっとした光の粒が生まれてきて
それはどんどん大きくなって光を見えてくるんです
それからさらに瞑想すると
いきなりこの光の対象と自分なんか一つになって
もう別にこちら自分がいて見てるんじゃなくて
ただ光だけになってしまっちゃう
それが第一禅定の状態なんです
で その時は体にはものすごくすっごい喜びが生まれてくるんです
もう絶対一般的には想像できないほど喜びと幸福感と気絶感が生まれてくるんです
で 認識を成長することだから
こここんな早くそんなことできませんよ
時間かかります 認識はこの成長することだから
その中でも指導があって
工夫いろいろあるんです
例えば一つはこのこの仕事
事務所と言ったっていいし
頑張ったのを持ち運ぶということがあるんです
瞑想を最後に最初にするときは
本当にあの対象を持っていって
どこかに入れて瞑想しなくちゃいけない
そこである日瞑想しちゃうと
瞑想しながら目を閉じるんです
目を閉じても見えるようになっちゃうんです
ということは 対象なくても頭でその対象の力を作られるという状態なんです
その場合は持ち運ぶ状態というんです
そこで持ち運ぶ 物ではなくて
心で持っていって 他のところに行って
座って目を閉じて あの対象を目で見るんです
心の目で 目で見て またパタウィパタウィパタウィと瞑想する
日本の方だったら見えてる見えてるとかそんな感じで瞑想して
そこでまた消えちゃったら
もうまたちょっとレベルダウンしたことになる
また対象のところに行って
また瞑想初めから始めて
また心で持ち運ぶ そこであの
その人は瞑想していて
いくらか成長したら まあちょっとした気をつけなくちゃいけない
できるだけ社会から離れてくださいと言ってるんです
日常の的なことから なぜかというと
見えるようになっちゃったら
こんないろいろ今いろんな色着てるでしょ
それ見えなくなっちゃうんです
集中してるんだから 心が集中してるんだから
この黒い色の服を見ても
この黒い色は純粋黒じゃないんです
その中には自分見た土色が入ってるんです
それだけ見えるんです
そうするとみんな同じ色を着てるんではないかと
顔を見ても みんな同じ土色の顔ではないかと
壁を見ても この壁の中にもあの土色あるんです
それ見えちゃうんですね
そうするとちょっと厄介なとこはあるんですね
それを知ってる人は大丈夫なんです
やっぱりそれでも買い物したりすると問題あるんじゃないんですか？人参選ぶ時は必ず問題が生まれるんですね
土色に見えちゃいますから
で 気をつけているならば大丈夫ですけど
人参も買うんだけど キャベツも買うんだけど
両方同じ色なんです 同じ土色で
ですから 結構そこら辺では厄介なんですね
ですから気をつけてくださいと
そこら辺気をつけて まあ頭おかしくなったとか思って怖くなっちゃったら
もうまた本当におかしくなってしまっちゃうし
ちょっとレベルがね 変わってるんだから
人があんたこれからバカになりますと言ったと同じように危ないんです
ですから 気をつけてやるもんなんですね
で 対象持ち運ぶあるいは見るものはその色で見える状態とか
いろんな変化があります
で それにめげずにこの徹底したこの素粒子レベルの光体験できるところまでやっちゃうんです
それになったら 脳細胞の中でも認識の過程の中でも
やっぱり物質の素粒子の関わりだから
一体感っていうのはさっと生まれてくる
光を通して これは視覚を
視覚というんですか 中心にやる瞑想なんですね
これ 聴覚中心にもできるし
味覚中心にもできるし
人間というのは視覚の方がすごくもう興味あるんだからね
で やりやすいんです そういうのはたくさんあります
大体いろんな世界宗教ではね
そんなことまで言ってるの
それ以上は進んでないんです
世の中の宗教っていうのは
神秘的なことを言ってる宗教でも
一体感だけありがたくみんな言ってるでしょ
あれはどんなものを瞑想したって一体感というのが生まれてくるんです
第1戦場 それから気安感
幸福感というのは確実に体の中で生まれるんです
それはなんとなく今幸せだな
幸福だなと言ってるような
そんなにそんなもんじゃないんです
幸せだなと言ったっても
お腹が痛いとか痛いし
お腹が空いたら苦しい
疲れるし 私は幸せでもう幸せいっぱいと言いながら
うちの奥さんがね もう大変苦労しているんだから
そんなものは幸福だと言わないんです
ほんのもんじゃなくて
純粋にこの心集中すると気安感
幸福感生まれてくる 至福感が生まれてくる
だからみんなその同じこと言ってるんじゃないですか
ヒンドゥー教の有名な言葉はサッチットアーナンダでしょ
サット リアリティ 真理
チット 心 魂 自分の魂 アーナンダってのは至福
ヒンドゥー教で瞑想してそれ体験するんです
ヨーガを瞑想して そこまでなんです
それ以上はないんです
進めないんです 煩悩は扱ってないんです
煩悩を扱ってないんだけど
煩悩は沈まない限りこの経験は出てこないんです
その人には欲望もうないんです
食欲も他の性欲ももう全部消えちゃう
なぜならばもう人間っていうのは何でお金欲しいや
なんで子供たち欲しい
なんであれ欲しいこれ欲しい
喜ぶためなんですよ 美味しいものを食べたいとか
でも何やったっても不完全な喜びなんですね
美味しいものを食べるためには苦労しなくちゃいけないし
子供たちがいて楽しいというためにはすごい苦労しなくちゃ
だから苦労の方が大きくて
幸福の方がほんのわずかなんですね
だから一生懸命欲が消えないんです
探し求めている そこで究極的な至福は感じちゃうと何もいらなくなっちゃうんです
だから煩悩は活動しない
仏教でいうのは煩悩は沈んだだけですと
至福感で それは煩悩が消えた状態じゃないんです
それは第1戦場の状態だけです
そういうことで いろんな宗教でおっしゃっている神秘体験っていうのは
まあ何のことないでたらめ嘘でもないんですよ
仏教の瞑想だけ正しくて
他の宗教の瞑想は間違ってるっていうことも
そうはそんなことではないんです
ヨガは良くない 仏教のヴィパッサナーだけ正しい
そんなくだらない話じゃないんです
ヨガは良くないわけでもないんです
方法は科学的に見ると似ているところは
仏教はただ単にこの瞑想の世界は心理学的に科学的に似ているだけ
そこでいろんな枠組みにカテゴリーに入れたら
どんな瞑想はどこまでやるかということはわかるんです
そのの中に自比俱捨の瞑想も入ってるんです
そこで禅定はどういう状態かというと
あの瞬間で自我が消えちゃうんです
対象が見えていて 光が見えてきて
見えてきて 光はいつでも外にあるんですね
自分が体験していて そこでどんどんこの光が光に自分が吸い込まれた
自分が光に吸い込まれたかと
どっちでもいいんだけど
そんなような感じが生まれちゃう
その瞬間で全く自我がなく
ただ意識だけ流れちゃうと
自我意識消えちゃう 自分で何もできない状態
そうすると心が流れていっちゃうと
それが禅定状態なんです
ヴィパッサナーで皆様もいろいろなさっているんだから
いつでも自分が見ているでしょ
それ禅定になっちゃったらヴィパッサナーできなくなっちゃうんです
だからヴィパッサナーにも禅定はそれほど役に立つものじゃないんです
禅定を作って落ち着いて
もう煩悩は抑えてもらったらものすごいやりやすいんです
でもヴィパッサナーする場合は禅定をカットして普通の認識に戻らなくちゃいけないんです
あちらから得られる得だけもらって
いわゆる煩悩は落ち着きましたと
もう色欲やら性欲やら睡眠欲やらもう何もない
普通の常識に戻っても何もない
こんなものはつまらないんだと
面白くないんだと 喜びも感じない
清らかな心なんです その心からまた普通の心に
ヴィパッサナーは普通の心でやらなくちゃいけない
ヴィパッサナーで禅定やら神秘体験がないと言って困る必要はないんです
生まれてこないんですから
生まれたらおかしいだけで
たまに生まれる場合もあります
その時は障害だと思って
それはカットしなさいと
ですから すごい難しいからくりなんです
この悟りの道っていうのは
普通の瞑想とはまた違うというのは
そういうところで違うということ
で 自分が本当にこれ第一禅定かないかというのは
別に瞑想では第一禅定か誰かがカバン看板持ってくるわけじゃないんですからね
だからみんな解釈しちゃうんですね
解釈で間違っちゃうんですね
例えばキリスト教の方々はいますね
あのモナストリというマンという神父さんたちがいるんですね
でお坊さんにモンスとモンクって言うんだけどね
そういう人々はいろいろ瞑想するんですね
で そういう人々がずっと瞑想したりすると
何か体験が得る 得る体験は解釈する
解釈は純粋にキリスト教聖書に基づいて解釈するんだから
キリスト教はこうそうという風になってしまっちゃいます
ですから 解釈はどうでもいいんです
解釈はいらない してはいけない
解釈は自分の文化でやっちゃいますから
そこでみんな神秘体験あってもバラバラなんです
喧嘩しちゃう ハレラーマグループともう他の宗教グループが喧嘩する
インドでもいろんな新興宗教グループいっぱいあるでしょうね
お互いに喧嘩するんですね
そこはこの解釈の問題で
だから解釈さえ置いておけば
瞑想っていうのはどんな瞑想でも心は落ち着きます
で それでこの禅定をどうやって理解しますかというと
今まで自分でこんな超越した体験していたのに
ある瞬間で体験自体だけ流れる
という自分頼りない もうどうしようもない
ただ体験だけ流れていっちゃう
あの瞬間が禅定の瞬間です
それは訓練次第によって
長い時間その瞬間でいることもできるんです
すぐ自我に戻っちゃうんです
戻ったらあの経験なくなっちゃいますけど
で 訓練して訓練して その状態で長い時間やれることはできるんです
じゃあそれはその世界の話なんですね
いわゆる認識を訓練して
認識のレベルを高くする
ただ 目で見えるものだけその通りだよというんじゃなくて
顕微鏡で見たら違うもの見えるんだからね
全く目で見えるものはその通りというわけじゃないし
科学的に見たって目に入るのは光ですから
光子見えた方が正しいなのに
でも光子は認識できませんし
目で光子見ようと思ったって見えませんだから
光子の巨大な束しか見えませんだから
大きな幻想になったものしか
そこでその光子そのものが見えてくるようになるということは禅定状態
まあそれ以上は進めないんですよ
認識では まあ進めますけど
ですから色界なんです
色に色を認識する世界だから
1つの対象がありますから
この色界に入ったら禅定が生まれたら邪魔が入りません
その時はもうかなり超越した心なんです
普通の神々とかね 普通の霊魂とかね
もう寄るどころじゃないんです
でもその過程ではいろいろ自分をいじめられたりするということはあります
そのいじめは本当に気をつけなくちゃいけない
もうとんでもないことになる恐れもあるんです
気をつけなくちゃ 普通の人にもあんた本当にバカですよと言ったって
あんまりもうちょっと腹が立って終わっちゃいますけどね
でもこれ徹底的に暗示かけても言っちゃったらものすごい危ないでしょうに
それから体も病気になるでしょうに
そういうことで この そういうのは気をつけてやる瞑想なんです
で お守りの中でも一番強いお守りっていうのは自信なんですね
しっかりすることなんですよ
何のお守りもいりません
人は体中お守りだらけぶら下がっているならば
それぐらい自信がない
不安がある 落ち着きがないということでしょ？それ別に不思議なことじゃないんだから
自信が出てくればくるほど
どんどんお守りが消えていく
たとえ誰でも大体お金の運がついてくるお守りとか持っていることもありますけど
たとえそれぐらいあっても
これはもうお金なければ困りますよ
ですから まあもうということで
それぐらいでも やっぱりお金に心配があるということなんです
ですから 人間に確実にお守り
お清めとか必要ということじゃないんです
これ 弱い人に必要なんです
ですから お守りの中で一番強いお守りっていうのは
自信があること 知識的にちゃんとした科学的にしっかりということなんです
それさえあれば何にもいりません
どんなお化け屋敷にも住めます
で だから古い時代ではいろんなこういうもうストーリーいっぱいあるでしょ？こういうなんか霊の話やらいろいろ
で もうあの山は神が住んでるんだから
もう大変危ない ちゃんとあのお供えいろいろしてやらなくちゃいけないとかあった時期あったでしょ？どんな国でもあるんですね
そういうものは でも今現代では何のことないでしょ
あれなんですかね 科学を発展して